[Music]
food jams
development
shipping
tourism new medicines innovation and
technology clean renewable energy
our ocean offers all this and more
this blue economy means hope and
prosperity for all the world's ocean
economy is currently estimated at around
1.3 trillion euros by 2030 it is
forecast to more than double aquaculture
offshore and ocean energy
blue biotech and tourism
I'll hold huge untapped capacity
especially in developing countries
training and education will be key to
success we need to equip a new
generation with the necessary blue
skills
and we need investment in sustainable
solutions
quick gains must be discarded in favour
of long-term goals to responsibly use
our shared resource for both present and
future generations to harvest the full
potential of the blue economy in a smart
sustainable and inclusive way how will
we reach across borders sectors and
disciplines
to make up reality
how do we ensure that the blue economy
doesn't just work for us but also for
our ocean
you
[Music]